[Musica]
allora il mio lavoro e
reporter di guerra sono una giornalista
e reporter di guerra
ho iniziato più o meno 25 anni fa perché
ho iniziato a fare questo lavoro
ma perché arrivo dalle guerre dei
balcani arrivo dalla ex jugoslavia e
sempre dato fastidio sentir parlare
delle guerre dei balcani noi
così in modo non corretto no e allora
credo che sia uno dei principali motivi
per cui io faccio questo questo lavoro e
questo è un po la mia storia è iniziata
un po dopo per vari motivi personali e
così via ma credo che la guerra
deve essere raccontata in modo corretto
perché la guerra mentalmente terribile
orrenda e tu non puoi essere
oc rita pensare a wordpress pensare ai
premi ci devi raccontarla deve
raccontare quello che vedi in un certo
momento ci sono delle persone che
veramente ti regalano loro ultimi beni
ti regalano
la loro storia ti permettono di fare
questa fotografia allora tu devi essere
rispettoso rispetto nei loro confronti e
rispettoso nei confronti delle persone
che poi sentiranno in questa storia
vedranno questa fotografia e credo che
rispetto è proprio la linea guida c'era
un po iniziato tutto così con la guerra
dei balcani ecco quando fai reporter di
guerra deve mettere in conto che non
esiste la sicurezza che quando parti e
tu potresti essere morire potresti
essere prossimo perché la vita la nuova
alleri e inter ci sono tu segui le
regole della guerra quando attraversi la
strada corre in due perché ci sono
cecchini che sparano e allora queste
regole quando perché c'è 50 per cento di
probabilità di delle perdite non uno
vive uno sopravvive e onore non so
quando cammini cammini vicino ai muri
perché queste sono
così non so se meno possibilità che ci
chiedi ti sparano e così via e allora la
sicurezza bombe cadono
non so tu dormi vestito tu dormi sempre
vestito con documenti addosso e allora
se il palazzo viene bombardato e ti
trovano almeno sanno chi sei oppure se
riesci scappare
almeno passaporto riesce a scappare la
sicurezza non c'è allora questo deve
metterlo in conto certo poi dall'altra
parte tre i contatti che nei contatti
con le persone che poi diventano la tua
guida perché una città grande e
bombardata e piena di cecchini e piena
di posti di blocco e tu devi sapere e
dove sono non lo sai allora queste
persone diventano la tua guida il tool
interprete e
diventano le persone la persona
che ti protegge perché giornalisti ecco
questo ci tengo proprio dire non portano
le armi se portano le armi non sono
giornalisti sono mercenari
non c'è la sicurezza di guerra 0 poi
altra cosa fondamentale è fondamentale
che poi dura mesi e la preparazione
perché tu prima di partire un paese devi
conoscere bene la storia del paese
geopolitica eccetera sono cose
fondamentali perché altrimenti diventi
turista di guerra quando tu sei un bel
ben informato quando hai studiato quando
ti sei informato non è che lo puoi fare
in tre giorni cioè
quando conosci
geopolitica è la storia che è
fondamentale sovente motivi delle guerre
eccetera
allora se un giornalista cioè senza
questa questa cosa qui tu diventi un
turista di guerra e
questo no questo è vietato questo non si
può fare
la fotografia diventa ultima cosa
così scatto diventa proprio ultima cosa
c'è per la preparazione è fondamentale
ed è quella che dura tanto prima di
partire fondamentale durante un
conflitto
le immagini possono fare
tanto di immagini possono
rassicurare
non lo so ma possono far rifletter
possono riflettere dove siamo quando
tutti noi pensiamo che una guerra fatta
nostro delle persone credenti non solo
di un dio tu scatendando una foto poi
far capire c'è chi è credente chi non è
credente oppure e smontare questo perché
bisogna quando tu vedi una foto di
osservare la foto perché ci sono piccoli
particolari che fanno sì che
si capisce non solo
sui muri puoi vedere anche non so dei
manuali non so di addestramento e
secondo me è importante anche guardare
le foto e vedere tu guardi vedi le armi
così si puoi capire anche traffici le
armi che ci sono perché queste sono
anche cose importanti una fotografia può
dire tante cose c'è una fotografia può
raccontare anche dei momenti come
realmente si vive cioè mi viene in mente
la ragazzina la figlia del medico in
ospedale
[Musica]
non so lui il curava le persone che
venivano durante i bombardamenti e lei
con fratellino sei anni lei 4 lui
prendevano questo
annaffiatoio che noi usiamo per
annaffiare le piante pulivano sangue
perché perché era più sicuro che loro
stessero con padre in ospedale che è con
non so a casa da soli
oppure
altro bambino perché i bambini le
persone normali sono più grande vittima
della guerra questo bisogna sempre
ricordarsi che
non so fuggendo dallo stato islamico
della città di racca che era la capitale
sono riusciti a fuggire durante i
bombardamenti
è finito come è diventato schiavo in
libano dove coltivavano le fragole per
un signore libanese è lui a sei anni è
diventato non so non è finito nelle mani
dello stato islamico per diventare
combattente è diventato schiavo
si le fotografie possono riflettere e
poi quando pensando adesso abdou lui si
chiama abdo
persone vedono a volte questa fotografia
è un bambino con la carota e molti che
bel bambino con la carrozza è no era
bambino che aveva unica cosa che va da
mangiare alla carota e le fragole e
allora va a volte la fotografia deve
essere anche spiegata perché giornalisti
fotogiornalisti non sono solo fotografi
sono di più devono essere di più non
basta solo la fotografia perché può
ingannare
nella vita delle persone io ritengo che
ci sono educatori cioè quando siamo
piccoli sono genitori poi ci sono
dei segnanti e poi quando cioè poi alla
fine siano i giornalisti perché quando
noi leggiamo la storia alla fine qualche
modo ci ci ci educa o diseducano
mettiamola così e questo dobbiamo
renderci conto che ruolo importante si
ricopre e dobbiamo portarlo con con
orgoglio
essere consci di questo giornalisti
durante un conflitto sono
devono informare devono informare e non
disinformare cioè devono raccontare
quello che succede devono ma senza
cercare senza pensare ai premi a
sorpresa
chissà cosa c'è devono raccontare quello
che realmente sta accadendo perché se
vedete adesso è un momento veramente
terribile perché le guerre vengono viste
in diretta io mi ricordo tanti anni fa
quando si diceva alle guerre saranno
trasmesse in diretta cioè veniva
rimasto male sentire questa cosa
e adesso è così perché tutti non so alla
fine mandando delle cose allora il ruolo
dei giornalisti è
riuscire a portare le notizie far
riflettere le persone riuscire a far
analizzare delle cose ma
essere neutrali più possibile ecco c'è
questo secondo me è fondamentale
attualmente nel mondo ci sono
circa 900 guerra no e allora noi c'è
purtroppo a volte diventiamo
siriani ucraini questo quello e non è
giusto secondo me è importante allora
essere contro tutte le guerre e dobbiamo
anche proteggere l'ambiente non possiamo
firmare accordi per l'ambiente poi non
so bombardare non so perché un giorno di
guerra inquina quanto 11 mila abitanti
in un anno cioè noi dobbiamo essere
contro tutte la guerra e urlare usare
tutti i social media possibili facendo
capire quanto le persone sono contro la
guerra non contro questa o quella contro
tutte la guerra perché secondo me se no
ci si autodistrugge
essere nel mondo sono uguali e questo è
importante perché non può essere non ci
può essere
differenza tra rifugiati
che hanno pelle nera rifugiati che non
solo hanno pelle bianca queste sono cose
veramente terribili e non sono anche
accettabili cioè io sono non so io ho
camminato con loro viaggiato con loro ma
siamo arrivati fino filo spinato ma
discorso era che erano un gruppo di
uomini iracheni e non siamo riusciti
passare sono arrivati i cani e ci hanno
mandate via la sensazione che arrivano
cane non sai se passano non passano e
una sensazione terribile e allora questa
differenza tra di trattamento perché una
persona è di un colore una persona di
altro colore c'è un
un discorso che il giornalismo deve
riprendere e deve uniformare c'è secondo
me non lo so
tutte le persone del mondo io credo che
sono uguale questo bisogna un po sotto
sottolineare
insistere su questo perché è solo
fortuna che nasce qui o là il mondo dei
giovani alla fine un mondo senza
frontiere è questo secondo me bisogna
lasciare alle future generazioni proprio
un mondo senza frontiere e libertà
grazie